c'est bon allez on y va c'est
parti Noël est terminé mais les animaux
du zo de Toir n'ont pas fini d'être gâté
cette année encore pour lutter contre le
gaspillage le parc a récupéré les
invendus des pépinières pour les
redistribuer à ses animaux j'ai préparé
du coup Manon des morceaux de poivrons
comme ça qu'on va mettre dans les
branches voilà c'est ça en style
décoration et puis et après ça sera tout
bon pour l'enclos d'goris ce sera sapin
agrémenté de poivrons l'objectif attirer
l'animal en mobilisant ses sens a
Tambo à peine déposé les sapins
rencontrent un vif succès mettant en
éveille la curiosité et la gourmandise
des
[Musique]
Goris
et pour les carnivores aussi les sapins
représentent un intérêt là les Panthères
elles vont pas le manger le sapin étant
donné que c'est des carnivores ça va pas
les intéresser mais par contre ça va
créer d'autres comportements et c'est
tout l'intérêt de l'enrichissement c'est
d'apporter une modification à
l'environnement d'avoir des stimulis et
de répondre à des comportements naturels
de l'animal on se sert du support du
sapin pour cacher de la nourriture pour
étaler du sang sur les branches et en
fait ça va stimuler la panthère à aller
chercher ses morceaux de viande à
l'intérieur il suffit juste de le lancer
donc je le passe par-dessus et ensuite
on va laisser les animaux s'y intéressés
l'objectif de ce partenariat avec les
grandes enseignes des alentours recycler
les sapins en leur donnant une seconde
vie gracieusement ils nous ont demandé
si on pouvait les récupérer donc c'est
quand même plutôt chouette ça donne une
seconde utilité à des sapins qui
finalement étaient destinés à partir à
la poubelle si tout n'a pas été mangé
dessus on peut les récupérer les broyer
et après ça nous sert à faire un couvert
autour de de nos au massif floral ou au
pied des arbres pour garder un maximum
de d'humidité et de minimiser les
arrosages qu'on devrait faire
normalement sur la végétation ici sur le
parc seule contrainte pour pouvoir être
redistribué aux animaux les sapins
doivent être naturel le parc a déjà reçu
une vingtaine de dons de la part des
enseignes partenaires pour le plus grand
plaisir des pensionnaires du
parc